heute werde ich schon mal nicht
verhungern wir haben heute nämlich eine
ganze Kiste Äpfel gesammelt und auf die
aller verschiedensten Arten für den
Winter haltbar gemacht ich habe gar
keinen Apfel Entkerner oder wie die
Dinger heißen deswegen hat mein Freund
hier so eine Wurst zu macht Tülle
genommen oder irgendeine Art Rohr die
wir in der Küche hatten und damit ging
es dann auch einigermaßen so dass wir in
Massenproduktionen gehen konnten ich
habe die Äpfel dann geschält und in
Scheiben geschnitten dann sind die in
den Dörrautomaten gewandert wir haben
nämlich Apfelringe hergestellt und
Apfelchips und auch fruchtleder wie das
geht habe ich euch ja in einem der
letzten Videos gezeigt und dann sind
ganz viele Reste übrig geblieben und
wisst ihr dass ihr daraus ganz einfach
Apfelessig herstellen könnt in den
glasfüllen mit Wasser auffüllen bisschen
Zucker rein und jeden Tag umrühren das
sind die ganzen Köstlichkeiten die wir
an dem Tag